i'm sorry brother
sorry that i brought you into this i
just wanted things to be the way they
used to be
that's my brother will i could use some
help my wife needs to search me this is
real life how's that right you put your
life down on the line for this country
you leave your family your home how much
do you need 231.
how about more
32 million and i need an extra men i
came to you for a loan look if i ever
got you anything that i couldn't get you
out of it's time for you to do something
for your family
what can i do you for officer we're just
doing a transfer from the back i'll let
you in in 20 minutes uh if i could just
get it done real quick because i'm on
the clock promise not to rob the place
seriously because that would be bad for
my job
my brother okay all right all right okay
let's go dave you are all gonna have the
greatest story to tell at dinner tonight
get out
don't shoot a cap
lock everything down
nothing gets out
[Music]
[Music]
just gonna borrow it i got a cop shot i
gotta get him to the hospital i'm gonna
need you to help us why don't you help
us we're doing hostages now
we're not crashing into this ambulance
we got a brother cop on board do you
have emt experience combat three eyes
you're a soldier yeah
we are
you think you're so tough with that gun
no daddy relax
i gotta get back to my life with my son
does your wife know you're all banks
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
wow
danny everybody knows how dangerous you
are do you
you get your helos out of here now
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother i'm gonna get everybody home
[Music]
[Music]
you